then he went on to talk about how you've
got to root out the activists at these
companies when you take over that might
be why you want uh why Mark Zuckerberg
hasn't done anything because he's just
got so many of them but Elon clearly had
no problem with it the percentage of
your staff did you fire at Twitter
one of the great business stories of the
year I think we're about we're about uh
20 of the original size so 80 left
uh yes
so a lot of people voluntarily for sure
sure but but it's 80 are gone from the
data correct yes so how do you run the
company with only 20 of the staff
uh turns out uh you don't need uh well
that many people to run Twitter but 80
that's a lot
um yes uh over I mean if you're not
trying to run some sort of uh
glorified activist organization uh with
it and you don't care that much about
censorship then you can really let go of
a lot of people turns out
without naming names but how many I had
dinner with somebody who runs a big
company recently said I'm really
inspired by Elon and I said you the Free
Speech stuff he goes no the firing the
staff stuff
um how many other CEOs have come to you
um
to talk about this I I spent a lot of
time at work uh so it's not like I'm
meeting with lots of people basically
what I what actions I've taken
um and um
but I think we just had a situation at
Twitter where it was absurdly
overstaffed you know so it wasn't uh you
know like you could say like what does
it really take to operate Twitter
um
you know most of what we're talking
about here is a group text service at
scale
um like
how many people are really needed for
that you know
um and if you look at the you say like
uh what has been the product development
uh over time with Twitter and you like
so like you know years versus product
improvements and it's like a pretty flat
line
so what are they doing
you know uh it took a year to add an
edit button that doesn't work most of
the time
I mean this is I feel like if it was a
comedy situation here you know
um
you're not making cars you know uh it
was very difficult to make cars
um or should get Rocket storage so
um you know the real question is like
how did it get so absurdly overstaffed
this is insane um
so anyway that's and it's clearly
working
um in fact I think it's working better
than ever it's about we've increased the
uh responsiveness of the system by in
some cases over 80 percent we're trying
to make make Twitter the most trusted
place on the internet the least
untrustworthy place on the internet I
don't think anyone should trust the
internet but but maybe we can make
Twitter the least untrustworthy so he
bought a very faulty product by his own
estimation right he called that thing uh
a fractal Rube Goldberg machine the code
in this thing is really messed up the
government was involved in this thing
there were activists at the organization
actively trying to take the company down
he bought it for a cool 45 Bill
something like that right and then he
fired or uh or some of them chose to
leave on their own as he said but about
80 percent of the people are gone so he
bought a faulty product with a whole
bunch of really bad useless employees
now the thing is slimmer and trimmer and
working and More in line with the values
that you and I share
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]